um I'm going to ask
the first uh two or three questions
on the subject of Ukraine we have
neither the
um chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee in order to do I know the
chair of the defense committee with us
but we have had a number of significant
events in recent weeks the president's
visits to Ukraine
um president zielinski's visit to London
and
last week we had the Secretary General
of NATO
confirming President Biden's prediction
that this will be a long war and I
wonder if I could just start by asking
you what alternative scenarios can you
envisage for the outcome of this war
that would be acceptable and in
particular
can you envisage any acceptable
circumstances which would leave Russia
in possession of any occupied Ukrainian
territory as part of a peace settlement
well thank you for having me sir Bernard
and I will do my best to keep the answer
short so we can indeed um end on time
and get everyone in quickly on Ukraine I
think the simple answer to your question
helpful is it's for Ukraine to decide
what is acceptable to them it's not for
anyone else to dictate to Ukraine our
job as I see it is to put them in the
strongest possible position to have that
conversation at a time of their choosing
to ensure that they can win this
conflict and in the immediate term my
priority has been to accelerate and
intensify our support to Ukraine with
the provision of particular capabilities
to ensure that they can have decisive
advantage on the battlefield uh over the
coming months and that's what our allies
I also know are committed to do I spoke
to President Biden about that and indeed
president macron when I saw them
recently were all aligned on that
strategy we've taken a lead in fact in
that strategy in the UK and that's what
the party is for now
um that would seem to be a no to the
answer in that case that if it's up to
Ukraine and your crime rate if you claim
that they want Crimea back as well we
would back them on that again this is
for Ukraine to decide our job is to put
them in the strongest possible position
to have those conversations at the time
that is appropriate second the budget
allocated extra money for defense uh
which I think the vast majority of
people most welcome but most of this
vital support has gone to support them
mod nuclear Enterprise Ukraine
urgently needs increased supplies of
weapons and ammunition if it is to hold
the current Russian offensive and to
drive Russia from its territory the
Secretary General of NATO has warned
that the whole of Europe needs to
replenish and renew weapons and munition
stocks and Supply chains to support the
long walk in Ukraine so can you explain
please prime minister how will the UK
increase its weapons and Munitions
acquisition so if those Earth to
replenish our national essential stocks
and simultaneously maintain supplies to
Ukraine at the rate which they are
needed well there's two separate things
Savannah one is the support we give to
Ukraine that is incremental to the mod's
budget there was 2.3 billion last year
and again this year we said we will meet
or exceed that same amount and so that's
the support we're providing second only
to the United States in terms of the
military support that we're giving
Ukraine and then the mod
budget was increased by 5 billion pounds
at the budget and that came on top of
the 560 million pounds uplift that they
received at the Autumn statement the
breakdown of the five is three for
broadly the nuclear Enterprise and two
for stockpiles and Munitions coming on
top as I said of the half a billion at
the Autumn statement and something that
I know the defense secretary warmly
welcomed at the time
but the money so far allocated
does not replenish the stocks we've
already given to Ukraine uh and does not
reinvigorate our supply chains in order
to support the supply of weapons needed
to both replenish our own stocks and to
continue supplying recurring so we are
doing both we are providing extra
financial support as I said second only
to the Americans last year in this
directly to Ukraine we are
simultaneously increasing the mod's
budget both to strengthen its nuclear
Enterprise and
um to increase our own stoppiles I would
make the the general observation as well
you know wouldn't necessarily see it as
a negative that the stock our own
stockpiles have been drawn down for the
simple fact that if you think about what
are those weapons four I mean they were
ultimately there to degrade and deter
primarily a Russian aggression they are
being used to do exactly that and
they're just being used by the
ukrainians so in one sense even though
the stockpiles are lower they are being
used for the purpose of which they are
intended and degrading the capabilities
of an adversary in the process so yes we
will rebuild them over time
um really the constraint is the supply
chain capacity which is not something
that we alone face or all our European
Partners face the same supply chain
constraints and that's something that we
are all collectively grappling with but
the money's been put in as I said
incrementally for the mod on top of the
money for Ukraine
I'm finally prime minister my last
question and this thread there was a
very notable
sino-russian Summit last week what
conclusions should we draw
from this Summit
and I don't think you've said anything
about this yet
so I you know my my observations on it
are you know whilst we welcomed and I
did Welcome China's support for
Ukraine's territorial Integrity as part
of the various things that they said I
think their abstention on voting for a
resolution it does little for their
credibility as a neutral party in this
you know I'd encourage president XI as
we've said to engage directly with
President zielinski on any particular
peace proposal that China is interested
in putting forward in that exactly is a
conversation I've had with President
zielinski as well China should would do
well to engage directly with Ukraine on
that you know more broadly it's clear
that Russia is dependent on China
for various reasons that are that are
obvious and again would ask president XI
to use his influence with Putin to urge
him to end this war and and withdraw
from Ukraine as a precondition to any
negotiations
um you're not supporting China's request
for a ceasefire no rather as I said that
there were various points in their peace
proposal and their support for Ukraine's
territory Integrity is indeed welcome
but as I said their actions elsewhere
and the other things they said as I said
undermine their credibility as being a
neutral party in this and you know I
said we were as as we have urged with
colleagues at other countries for China
not to supply Russia with weapons and to
ask them to use their influence with
Russia to try and bring an end to this
conflict
thank you prime minister we'll move on
to the topic of the budget
Harriet Baldwin for the treasury
committee
thank you very much chair and prime
minister three of your five priorities
this year are economic priorities
halving inflation growing the economy
and reducing debt uh one quarter in how
would you see those going
well you know you would have seen the
report from the obr at the time of the
budget and we are we are on track with
all of those OVR forecasts inflation uh
to be more than halved by the end of the
year but of course as we saw most
recently right this is not easy never
said it would be easy so it's important
that we stick to the plan uh with regard
to reducing debt again budget confirm
that we're meeting our fiscal rules uh
with the reduction of debt percentage of
GDP and lastly in terms of growing the
economy I think all the data I think the
obr said was the largest upgrade to
near-term growth forecasts since they've
been doing this uh now actually you know
a forecast that we would avoid a
technical recession and the recent
survey data from the various pmis is
again surprised on the upside
um as as indeed to the January GDP
numbers so yeah of course I think we are
making progress but particularly with
combating inflation we cannot be
complacent it's important that we stick
to the plan
so you're not worried that inflation
actually Rose last month because the OVR
is forecasting that it will come down
the obr also forecasting that this year
the economy won't grow and of course we
are still running a budget deficit so
those things don't don't concern you I
think I particularly said actually the
recent inflation number
reminded us that we should not be
complacent about inflation it's
important that we stick to the plan and
if we stick to the plan then I believe
that we will be able to reduce inflation
over the course of the year but these
things Don't Come Easy you have to work
for them it's important you have fiscal
discipline it's important that we
continue to act on the supply side of
the economy to ease some of those
inflationary pressures that's what the
budget does and various things that I'm
sure we'll talk about which will help
achieve that whether it's the
intervention on energy that will bring
down inflation or the actions to improve
the supply of labor those are all
important things discipline on public
sector pay for example so that's that's
why I think it's a set of one that we
stick to the plan on inflation with
regard to debt you know these this is
something that is going to have to
happen over time of course given the
shocks that we've experienced but what
we've said about debt falling as a
percentage of GDP by the end of the
forecast period is a rough test for that
that is forecast to be met as it was
indeed in Autumn and in the most recent
budget but also a forecast to be running
a current balance as well by the end of
the period which is which is also extra
and welcome
but specifically on inflation the
chancellor told us that the freezing of
fuel Duty for another year and uh the
extension of the household cap took
about 0.75 off it what inflation would
otherwise be
um but the fuel Duty measure uh just
simply kicked the temporary 5p uh down
the road for another year and I just
wondered prime minister if you think
that the chancellor is likely to raise
fuel Duty in an election year in the way
that is now in the obr's numbers that
you just cited I I have a feeling we
have the same conversation when we were
last here Harriet and I'm gonna have to
give you the same answer that I did then
that I'm not going to comment on any
future tax policy
um though I just uh it it is the reason
I keep going on about this is because
you know clearly it is a fiction now in
the in the in the fiscal forecast I
don't think that the chancellor is going
to raise field Duty by 12 Pence next
year in an election year but I will just
leave that out there on growing the
economy specifically
um the the main measures in the budget
were sort of letting the super deduction
expire replacing it with a full
investment expensing uh raising business
taxes and the obr is forecasting the
economy won't grow this year so on a
scale of one to ten how confident are
you that we'll see a growing economy
against your objective this year I said
the economy is forecast to return to
growth by the end of the year which is
what I talked about when I made the
speech at the beginning of the year and
I think the measures and chances budget
will help Drive long-term growth
particularly their policy to move
towards full expensing over time and
immediately temporarily for the next
three years if you look at the
productivity gap between the UK and some
of our major competitors like France and
Germany it's a lack of business
investment that explains about half of
that productivity Gap we've perennially
been an economy that under invests in
capital relative to almost all our major
peers and but with the chancellors for
expensing policy you know we will now be
the most attractive place for companies
to make those Investments and and I
think that is something that will
ultimately drive up our long-term growth
I was very pleased that in the survey of
about
three or four thousand CEOs from over
100 countries that PWC did recently they
ranked the UK as the number one European
destination for investment and the third
globally behind only the U.S and China
so that again gives me some confidence
that the policies we've caught in place
you know are attracting attention from
the right people and we'll see the
benefits of that over time
of the obr mentioned the fiscal rules as
as well as uh the the point that you
were just making but they made it
slightly differently they said that
actually their Chancellor had left very
little room for maneuver in terms of the
five-year forecast and uh there are many
things in the budget that the chancellor
aspires to spend money on aspires to
increase defense spending aspires to
continue the investment allowances past
three years as far as to go up to 0.7
when the conditions allow in terms of
the a budget and
um they even told us the obr that these
these different rules mean that
effectively uh the finances are on a
ratchet because whenever there's a
positive surprise there's something that
the chancellor wants to spend money on
and presumably that you would support
and uh yet uh you know whenever
something bad happens the deficit has to
increase again so it seems to be on a
one-way according to the obr what are
your thoughts on that no I to the point
on the fiscal rules it's important to
remember that
actually what they were talking about in
terms of Headroom was the degree to
which it the Delta the change from the
fourth to the fifth year the actual
overall level of debt was lower across
the forecast period lower debt interest
payments lower overall amounts of debt
so in that sense of public finances
undoubtedly strengthened since
um since the Autumn and I think that's
something we should all be thankful for
look going forward you're right you
identify
um lots of areas of pressure which is
why you know when I made the commitment
on Aid as as Chancellor and more
generally when we make commitments you
know they are subject to the fiscal and
economic circumstances and ultimately
the best way to pay for the things that
we'd like to spend money on is to have a
growing economy and that's why you know
your your earlier question about the
investment incentives is so important
and why the Chancellor's measures in the
budget to increase labor Supply are
important if we can his measures indeed
to improve regulation in our growth
industries particularly life sciences
and if we can get those things right
then actually we will have higher growth
and that's ultimately the best way to
afford to invest in all the things
whether it's not security or anything
else that we collectively think is
important
thank you prime minister
um Steve Bryan thank you very much
um one could say that you're gaining a
reputation as a problem solver and
there's one area where
that looks to be true also is the the
winter NHS pay dispute in particular
with the nurses and the the provisional
agreement with the agenda for change
unions which obviously is just wider
than the nurses but you'll know that
there's some anxiety out there that if
these agreements reads that are
confirmed through their through the
unions or where the money is going to
come from to pay for those those
increases so will it come from existing
budgets or is there going to be extra
funding to the trusts that have to pay
those settlements and I think taking a
step back I'm very pleased that we were
able to reach agreement with several
Health unions on a fair and reasonable
pay settlement for about 1.4 million NHS
workers it's right that they're paid
fairly and rewarded for the Fantastic
work they do whether it's nurses
midwives paramedics or others but also
important you know just referring back
to Harry's questions that that was
affordable for the taxpayer and
consistent with our promises the heart
of inflation and cut the waiting list
and I think we've struck the right
balance and I think you would have seen
I hope the comments from the health
secretary today that did provide the
reassurance that people were looking for
and after course there are always
conversations between departments and
the treasury that and I wouldn't want to
get in the middle of precisely by the
health secretary provided strong
reassurance about additional funding as
well as reprioritization from elsewhere
but making sure the commitment to
continue delivering care and all our
commitments are cut waiting lists is
absolutely Paramount and protected and I
think that's been warmly welcomed by the
sector yes thank you thank you for that
so turning to uh pretty much the link
subject which is NHS recovery which I
know is something that you care deeply
about so last February the elective
recovery plan for tackling the the covid
backlog on elective care was published
is that on track or even beating the
Target that you were expecting by this
point
yeah I think broader broadly on track
you see we we talked about it earlier
this year as well I mean look the
waiting list is up to about seven
million we all know the reasons why
we set out a few Targets in that plan
the first was to eliminate two-year
waiters which was practically done last
year the next Target is to eliminate the
one and a half year waiters this spring
and we're broadly on track for that
obviously you know the junior doctors
industrial action may have an impact on
that but we are on track uh other than
the industrial action to to hit that
like pay enormous tribute to the trusts
and everyone involved in making good
progress on that and Jim Mackey in
particular who's leading the charge
um and then the target after that is to
practically eliminate the 52 Week
waiters by um around spring of next year
and so as I said the most the immediate
Target is the is the one for this spring
pending the industrial action we're
making good progress on it and thanks
for a lot of hard work from a lot of
people elective activity at the moment
is running at about 106 of pre-pandemic
levels and testament to the all the
initiatives we put in place working but
of course we do need to drive that
number higher and that's what the plan
is for the rest of this year so just to
pick up then on that next Milestone the
ifs said last month and they looked at
this that we were Within Reach of the
18-month Target by April so obviously
April comes later this week
um I just wonder how much how worried
are you how much of a dent has the
industrial action among the agenda for
change group and the ongoing industrial
action of course among the junior
doctors which you just referred to
yourself how much of a dent is that
making in the progress for elective
recovery as I say it does make it harder
um but we were we were on track up until
now because I said we've been working
very hard and the teams deserve enormous
credit obviously there's future
industrial action to come and then we'll
have to see you know how the NHS is able
to cope with that more broadly and it
may well have an impact but as I said
absent that we're very much on track and
I said there's a lot of people working
very hard
and as a result of all the initiatives
we put in place whether it's elective
surgical Hearts Community diagnostic
Centers and the like the targeted
support for particular trusts all of
that is working and uh you know so I
said we're going to keep at it because
it's important I said you're a problem
solver
can you apply that to the junior
doctor's dispute which obviously at one
point during the the nurses dispute that
looked rather intractable you seem to
have got to an agreement there subject
to Union approval
what how how confident or
not confident are you in doing the same
with respect to the junior doctors so I
look we've always maintained the same
approach throughout these things but we
that we would like to and are happy to
have constructive conversations with
unions to find ways through these pay
disputes our approach has always been
the same we want to make sure that
people are rewarded fairly for the work
they do as I said whilst that being
affordable for the taxpayer and
consistent with our need to bring down
inflation because ultimately it's
inflation that's making people's living
standards
um you know less healthy than they would
like it's inflation that's causing
people's bills to go up and we want to
make sure we don't contribute to that
and that you know that's the balance we
always want to have conversations that
can find a way through that we continue
to be open to talking I'm pleased as I
said we've found resolution with 1.4
million NHS workers a half a dozen
unions or so similarly you've seen in
other areas that we are trying to find
ways through our door is always open do
you think that's set just fine do you
think that sets the context for peace
because George Orr is always better than
World War and obviously the growing
waiting lists as a result of the
indented at least by by just make some
of the work life balance the workload
challenge that our Junior doctors
understandably complain about just makes
that worse what would your message be to
them and their Union yeah look we you
know I am government Health secretary we
hugely value the work that all doctors
Junior doctors do we're keen to find a
way through this and that's fair and
reasonable for for taxpayers as as
people can see we're clearly able to
find that resolution elsewhere in the
NHS let alone in other sectors so I
don't think anyone can say that we're
not being constructive about these
things I think the BMA had placed a
precondition on the talks of something
like a 35 pay rise I think almost
everyone if not everyone would see that
that is unreasonable and unaffordable
and but our door is always open to have
genuinely constructive and reasonable
conversations thank you Jim
thank you um
Jane Meg Hillier from the Public
Accounts committee thank you very much
where it comes from as the chair of the
health select committee highlighted so
can you just revisit that and tell us if
you can be any reassurance to hospital
trusts right now about whether it's
going to be expected how much you might
be expected to come from their budget
and how much could will come from
Whitehall you know I can't add much more
to what I've said to Steve earlier and
you would have seen the specific
comments from the health secretary
earlier about yeah this is the last week
of March hospitals need to know how to
budgets and if you look at the modeling
for South teas NHS trust which covers
some of your constituency it you model
the figures two percent of six percent
it's between 7 million and 22 million
pounds the University Hospital
Southampton to take another part of the
country it ranges between 10 million
extra and 29 million extra for that
trust that's a lot of money that
hospitals could have to have out of
their Frontline budget while as you say
they're trying to heroically achieve
over a hundred percent in fact over a
hundred and twenty percent of
productivity in 2019 levels to catch a
catch up how do you expect them to
square that Circle I'd say it's
important to remember that the NHS were
already funded for a 3.5 pay rise for
this forthcoming year and so the
incremental is is less than the total
amount and again at the Autumn statement
there was the announcement of 14 billion
pounds over the next two years of
incremental funding for the NHS and
social care those allocations are also
being made but as a health secretary
said today there will be additional
funding there will also be
re-prioritization as there always is
those conversations are ongoing the
trust will be notified in the normal way
but that reassurance as far as I can see
today has been welcomed by the sector
and they understand that the details
will be coming out soon okay would you
like to prefer in future to see one more
steadier Health funding announced
earlier so that hospitals can plan
better we traditionally have seen for
example Health funding for the winter
crisis of not reaching hospitals until
November which is pretty useless when
you're trying to plan a winter crisis do
you make any commitments to the NHS for
more stability I think this is only
because the pay settlement was only
resolved recently so it's hard hard to
have had that conversation
what about next winter because that's
why the Autumn statement actually
announced funding for the next two years
14 billion pounds not just for the NHS
for social care so and you're you're
saying is the commitment that you're
getting sure the hospitals have that and
sort of notice from now onwards yeah
look there's the department for Health
and Social care will do all its
allocations in in the normal way and
they're having those conversations in
general you know it's always good to be
able to give people certainty as early
as possible but it's also important to
work through with the trust exactly how
that money is going to be used to ensure
that as I'm sure you would want to do we
get value for the taxpayer and you know
if we're giving money out to trust or to
social Care Systems to achieve
particular aims whether it's on
discharge for example which is where
some of that social care money is going
it's important that we know if we're
putting incremental social care money
into the system or what is that actually
going to buy us in terms of better
discharge a reduction delay transfers of
care and so it does take time to put in
place those accountability things and
many other conversations we've had where
there's this tension between get the
money out fast get the money out fast
then when you get the money out fast and
it doesn't quite deliver what you want
it's like why do why did you get what
you want this is all bad for the
taxpayer so we just need to get that
balance right I generally do want to
give certainty because that helps people
plan but it's right that when we give
the money we know what we're getting for
it that's the right thing to do thank
you chair I'm tempted to draw parallel
get money out fast on the bounce back
loans fraud level wow
it's actually I was referring apparently
to that because this is exactly well
that's exactly the exactly the potential
I think I think I remember you asking me
in the chamber when I was Chancellor
again everyone was the this is the thing
when people want the money out quickly
you have to accept that there is an
inherent trade-off between those things
it's always difficult to get the balance
perfect we should accept though that
there is a trade-off and if we want
accountability that takes a bit of time
to get right if we want to be then we
have to trade a bit on the campus
Jefferson's sake has been our refer
colleagues to the Public Accounts
committee's back catalog on bounce back
loans and fraud um which I'm sure people
are aware of thank you disability
um
Mr Stewart the transport committee oh
thank you Joe good afternoon prime
minister I'd like to turn to the the
pre-budget announcement uh there's a
number of strategic transport uh
Investments are being rephased uh the
cost uh inflationary cost pressures in
construction of course are
understandable but many are arguing that
the delays to hs2 are actually a false
economy and that the stop-start nature
of the project changing the school will
actually cost more in the long run we do
not agree it might be better just to
carry on with the original timetable
yeah thank you um Ian let's let we
remain completely committed to hs2 it's
a significant investment in our national
infrastructure and I think it's right
given that we've already spent about 20
billion pounds on phase one
um that's where we should prioritize
delivery and as you acknowledge and
thank you for doing so in in light of
the inflationary pressures you know
we're going to use the next couple of
years to rephase some of the projects
and to optimize the delivery
particularly of phase 2A and so that we
can do that the most cost effective way
you know I think we share the same
ambition which is to deliver value for
the taxpayer um for this conversation
previously with with Harriet about the
fiscal situation so I think we've got
the right balance and now there's a you
know strong degree of accountability
over hs2 how it's spending the money I
think for all of our sakes it's right
that money spent well but given the
inflationary pressures it does make
sense to reface some of those things but
would it not be better perhaps to look
at alternative sources financing hs2
other than it's simply coming from uh
from government funds uh don't wish to
return to the horrors of some of the PFI
projects in the past but the budget did
contain a number of uh initiatives the
UK Investment Bank for example so
infrastructure bank for example are
using uh pension or Insurance funds
if we could be found to leverage in some
of that money do you think there's it
would be sensible to revisit the
timetable
I'm not aware that that is a possibility
I'm not sure that anyone has come
forward with any suggestions like that
you might be more um closer to it than I
am and government in general at all you
know is always open to having
conversations with the private sector
about where they want to invest in the
UK particularly in infrastructure where
we're because of some of the reforms
we're making to solvency 2 as a result
of brexit we do hope to unlock money
from the insurance industry for
investment in long-term projects like
infrastructure for example and so that's
that's always going to be welcome I'm
not sure if it would make sense on this
particular project but I'm sure the
transport secretary's door would always
be open to if people want to come and
talk to him about helping to fund some
of these things thank you um and I'd
like just to focus specifically on the
section of hs2 from all.com and to
Houston uh first they can you confirm
this it will go to Houston there have
been a couple of statements recently
where it was somewhat ambiguous but is
it absolutely the intention to build it
to too used to the not Terminator yes I
mean it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
ambiguous and I think it it's it gets
back to this affordability and profiling
profiling issue over the next couple of
years and I think the aim is to deliver
the transport secretary said is that the
aim is to deliver that station alongside
the rollout to to Manchester and to take
the time now to get the right
deliverability for that particular
section
but on the this is not the first
redesign of Houston uh it was done a
couple of years ago as part of the Orca
V review why didn't hs2 get it right
then
yeah I uh I guess I can't uh
unfortunately I can't answer to that ago
I wasn't uh responsible for it at the
time but I think it is important that I
said we get it right now these things
cost billions of pounds they're
important projects and we need to make
sure that we do deliver value for the
taxpayer and we're doing things that are
gonna gonna actually be deliverable so I
think it's reasonable
um that it is done properly now and
that's what's that's what's happening
I'm not sure if it was looked in that
much detail at the time obviously things
have progressed since then there's more
detail to do it's the next stage of
development that it's important that we
get right but the the current work
that's going on at Houston I see it
every time I go in and out of uh using
on the train to my constituency it was a
heck of a lot of work been going on
that's not going to be wasted well I I I
wouldn't imagine Sarah said I'm the
transport secretary is is busy doing
doing that work and making sure that we
can get it right and let's explain that
but I said the plans are there for the
not just the fusion tour don't common
but phase one and then obviously we'll
get to phase 2A and Beyond as well okay
thank you prime minister
um thank you Mr Stewart um
the Public Accounts which actually had a
visit to Houston Station this morning
seriously and um it reminds us that in
October of last year
um hs2's local Growth Action Plan uh
well we were told that the government
would be publishing that action plan
later at the end of last year of course
in March this into a month you've made
the announcement but there were poor was
on Houston some of the subcontractors
there have over 50 of their order book
at Houston they're now having to pause
for two years do you think this is
really a way of helping to grow the
economy premise well I think it's
important that we also get things right
for the taxpayer more generally the hs2
project is I think supporting almost 30
000 jobs and almost 3 000 businesses the
bulk of which are smes and
overwhelmingly obviously based in the UK
and I think over its time it will also
create one or two thousand
apprenticeships along away as well so as
a project it's already doing an enormous
amount to support the economy small
businesses apprenticeships and jobs more
generally but it's important that we get
big infrastructure projects right that
we take the time to get them right and
that's what's happening with that bit of
it but I think that when some projects
got momentum and it keeps going those
small businesses you mentioned and
others know that there's worth worth
their time putting the money and effort
in they're often bid for these contracts
for some of those small businesses they
if they lose that level of the order
book over twos they will withdraw
um today some of the staff are saying
that we're a great big jobs going in
Canada in Dubai there are other parts of
the world that these companies go and go
and work in if we're really trying to
grow the economy don't you think that
the government's shooting itself in the
foot with a delay like this on top of
previous delays which were admitted to
you weren't in the driving seat for
which just suggests that Britain just
can't get on with delivering big
infrastructure projects I think it's
important that we get the big
infrastructure projects right that we do
them properly they cost a lot of money
it's reasonable that we make sure
they're going to be done on budget
reasonable pause for two years is that
about getting it right well it is we're
taking the time to make sure it can be
delivered within budget they're given
inflationary pressures it's involved and
we get that right and I think actually
90 I think 97 of the businesses do the
small businesses are UK based and as I
said something like almost thirty
thousand jobs so some of them don't go
under as a result of this pause I think
there's there's a I mean it is a massive
investment tens of billions of pounds I
think that's supporting plenty of jobs
and plenty of businesses up and down the
country
prime minister towards the end of the
last Labor government I recall
the carrier build was delayed for two
years for an India saving of 150 million
pounds but it added 650 million pounds
to the cost of the program have you done
the same calculations for this pause for
Houston yeah I think the transport
secretary spoke about it detail at the
time
um but again I I think it is the right
thing given the size of these projects
and you know I think Harriet's questions
at the beginning will write about the
fiscal position and indeed the plans
there and all the other spending
pressures I think in light of the
inflation that we've been experiencing I
think it's absolutely right that we take
the time to get these big infrastructure
projects right that we know that they
can be delivered properly that we they
can be delivered on budget and I think
that's the right thing to do for the
country and the taxpayer and again we're
cracking on with a 20 billion pound
investment from Aldo common to
Birmingham in the meantime that's a huge
investment it's one of the biggest
transport projects anywhere and and
that's being delivered so we should you
know we're focusing on this bit of it
from old oak common to Houston let's not
forget although comment uh to Birmingham
that is a 20 billion pound investment
phase one that is
so you didn't give me the numbers I I
don't have them to hand I said the
transport section I think would have
addressed them at the time maybe you
could write to us about that
um uh Susan Crabb language repairs
committee thank you prime minister un
Wales last week we're announcing two
free ports you were talking a lot about
investment in new green energy did you
sit in the discussion between a view
that says look we just need to attract
as much investment into these new green
technologies whether that's floating
offshore wind or hydrogen and get the
stuff scaled up or a view that says no
we need to take the time and and spend
more money up front to build an
industrial strategy and to build
domestic capabilities and Supply chains
in the UK where do you lean in that
discussion so I'm not sure see when I
quite understood the difference but I
think my my general approach would be
you know we need to do a mix of
innovation investment because often it
government has a particular role to play
when it comes to r d and that's why our
record r d budget that we've protected
is really important to our future growth
particularly particularly
with the transition to to Net Zero and
and creating the jobs and companies of
the future so I think we have a big role
to play there that's what we should be
doing alongside that is making sure we
have a Workforce that so again the
government will have a role on on skills
and then I think what's incredibly
important and what companies say to us
is something that the UK does better
than most people is creating regulatory
Frameworks for for things like as we did
contract contracts a difference for
offshore wind as we will do for carbon
capture and storage sustainable aviation
fuel hydrogen floating offshore wind Etc
so those regulatory Frameworks are are
critical for giving private companies
the confidence to invest and ultimately
we need far more private investment than
we do public and then you know that as
an attracting private Capital more
generally I think there are
opportunities to do that with the new
institutions here mentioned earlier the
UK infrastructure Bank being a fantastic
example and then the last bit of it I'd
say is just the overall business
environment and you know we've talked
about how discussion another about flood
expensing for example if you're making
these big Capital Investments you know
knowing that there's a tax regime that's
supportive of that is also valuable so I
think those are all the ingredients of
it freeports you know our particular
areas where there are tax advantages
that attract investment to them but you
need all the other ingredients too can I
ask you about the the crown estate which
you'd have obviously had a lot to do
with in one of your previous roles in
government they stand to make enormous
amounts of Revenue if this vision of
expanding floating offshore wind comes
about do you not think there's a role
there rather than the revenues from the
crown estate just disappearing into the
treasury coffers for dedicating a
portion for that to investing in UK poor
infrastructure making sure that there
are permanent jobs and and companies
developing around these homegrown
Industries well I think we are investing
in Port infrastructure
um and I think actually that's one of
the things I think I announced as
Chancellor was the uh
um an infrastructure I call
infrastructure fund for offshore wind
and that will help us as we do more
manufacture ring in the UK having poor
infrastructure that can handle the new
size of the turbines and things and then
be able to export them is critical part
of that I feel like it was 160 or
something a couple hundred million
pounds I think one of those Investments
has gone in t-side but also the
chancellor recently announced a similar
fund for floating offshore wind which
will be particularly of interest in
Wales and people were very excited about
it when I was there last week and again
this is when you do our industrial
strategy and all the rest of it at the
end of the day we as a country have a
couple of very specific natural
competitive advantages carbon capture
and storage in the North Sea is a
geological Advantage we have that others
don't floating offshore wind is a
capability that we've developed more so
than anywhere else in the world huge
export potential and so you know we are
building on those strengths there is
capital funding available for some of
those infrastructure improvements and
indeed where I was last week you know I
think it's benefiting from some of that
great and I mean all of this is very
complicated as well delivering floating
offshore winds upgrading grid capacity
and all of that kind of thing
um your predecessor but one um
appointed a range of
Champions within government to lace
together strategies across Whitehall my
understanding is that their jobs have
come to an end who do you see is
responsible for for really driving
forward these complicated cross-cutting
strategies to deliver on the the green
energy vision
well I mean ultimately you know we we
have a you know I'd say it depends
depends on the exact thing that you're
that you're talking about Stephen also
you know Grant is doing a superb job in
the new department for energy security
and Net Zero and we'll be talking about
this
um talking about this more soon but you
know we're continuing to work with I
think the energy Champions that you're
talking about
um that we've appointed in the past I'm
trying to remember and on hydrogen I
think it was Jane too good was appointed
and then it was Tim pick I think on
offshore wind
um so I and I think we've already
delivered
I think almost all of the
recommendations of the person who was
brought in to help launch Great British
nuclear for example so we do use that
outside expertise as well uh obviously a
lot of this requires industry
cooperation but you know Grant has done
a great job believing that the
chancellor where you know there are
Finance components um as well but as I
said I think the Machinery of government
changes we've made have really helped
bring it together Grant scripting it and
then we'll continue to work with some of
these Champions and other external
bodies as well and can I just ask you
quickly about economic inactivity
because the budget had a lot to say
about that there's a useful package
there that was announced by the
chancellor
um it wasn't clear to me though what we
think what we hope the the NHS will be
doing differently as a result
what do you want to see the NHS do
differently to tackle Britain's economic
inactivity and the sheer numbers of
people of working age being signed off
very long term
on the sixth so I mean look there's
there's a lot of detail that they've put
out you know in terms of msk for example
of musculoskeletal conditions and other
things which of course maybe not get
dragged into the weeds of but I think
that was the main area of focus but I
think that strategy is broader than any
just one department and I think there's
no there's no symbol single simple thing
that will help solve the problem we've
accommodate lots of different ways but
you know I was encouraged that I think
the obr said that it was the biggest
supply side package that they they'd
ever seen in terms of trying to tackle a
problem like this in terms of the impact
they think and will have on the labor
market it's a mixed addition and
different initiatives whether on the
health side but also the welfare side
tax side and
um and other fit notes for example that
was trailed in the in the Press leading
up to the budget that didn't that didn't
last I said I mean I tend not to comment
on the Press speculation I think what's
in the budget is what is what we're
delivering
um but I think there's a broader point
which helps that create chance and
others have made in the past that work
you know work can be helpful to people's
mental health in particular and I think
that's something that many people
acknowledge and I think there has been
some talk on making sure that that is
acknowledged in guidance and and that
may be the part that I I don't know the
speculation or the pressing that you're
particularly talking about but that is
something that people have spoken about
in the past and making sure that
guidance around Fitness does capture
that and I think that's a reasonable
thing for for it to happen but again
these are conversations that I think
combination of Peace acting as
Gatekeepers to the benefits a
combination of you know our health
experts and and people on the welfare
side making sure that they joined up to
get that kind of guidance and advice
right thank you very much Mr grab the
musically on time Catherine mckennell
petitions committee thank you chair um
announcements in in the budget will
warmly welcomed by the child care sector
for what they're going to do which is to
increase the funding for child care as
it is now but also expand the provision
to cover some of the gaps in the
existing system and move us into an
internationally I think quite generous
position relative to our peers on on
Child Care
um and it's it's a really important area
it's something that the chancellor I
think addressed very comprehensively in
the budget
so I mean I think parents currently
spending 30 of the household income
often more than their mortgage on Child
Care would say it is currently in crisis
and they're the parents that can access
child care there are many that can't and
can you explain
given there is a crisis I think for many
households why someone with a
two-year-old today will not benefit from
any of the additional funding
um ever
so just let's be clear so it is clear
that we have um relative to other
countries more expensive Child Care
they've taken steps to address that
actually one of the tweaks that was made
and changes is on the on the ratio is on
the on the ratios and that will help
ensure that there's actually potential
for more competitively provided Child
Care bringing us in line with other
peers and then in terms of the rollout
of the extra provision that the
chancellor announced I think there's a
couple of things one is that there's
going to be a very rapid increase in the
funding rate for the existing programs
very significant increase and that's
happening relatively quickly and the
reason it takes time to roll out the
very substantive increase in in
provision is because it takes time to
recruit more child minders and it's
right that it's done
um and delivered properly and that
that's what's taking time yeah so it's
helpful that you've mentioned Workforce
challenges because that is one of the
big barriers to actually delivering
anything that the government is
currently promising and you mentioned
ratios we know many concerns have been
expressed that that is going to
significantly reduce quality some many
have raised safety concerns particularly
petitioners
um who lost their child very tragically
at nursery and are very concerned about
the ratios being reduced and but also
that is one of the only measures that
the government has suggested to increase
the workforce the other one is child
minders and increasing the number of
child minders can you explain
why the government's chosen to give a
600 pound bonus if you sign them as an
individual as a child minder but if you
go through one of the six private child
care agencies that you get a 1200 pound
bonus a double bonus
can you can you explain the logic behind
that yeah I mean I said I think this has
been designed in consultation with the
sector to make sure that it's perfect
child care agencies I said well I think
it's been designed the second I'm happy
to get back to you remember only six
childcare agencies and they're advertise
on the government's website what
conversations has the government had
with these agencies about these
proposals I'll happily right back to you
and the in the committee on uh on
exactly what conversations are had and
and the rationale for that the use of
tax base money to give double bonuses to
sign it with private agencies well I
think it's a reflection of the fact that
they're through intermediaries so
they're additional costs and Ultra you
just want to make sure the policy is
effective in bringing additional people
into the system because I think and
there's nothing investor wishes to
declare in respect of that no I mean all
my all my disclosures are declared in
the normal in the normal way
um but I think as as you said Catherine
the policy is King we're keen to roll it
out as quickly as practical and one of
the reasons that you can't do that
overnight is because you need to improve
their Workforce and Visa policies that
are targeted at improving the supply of
child minders so that we can increase
provision of child care which is
something that I think everyone wants to
see so I think it's been entirely
reasonable thing to to do you talked
about ratios I mean I I think that you
know it's more reliable I think they're
just bringing the ratios in line with
the ones in Scotland
it's not I don't think it's that
dramatic and also again ultimately it's
it's just a Erasure no it's it's the
minimum um it people don't have to uh
they don't have to use it right they can
choose to do something different parents
can make that choice and that's
something that people will be able to
make their own views on but I think in
the same breath if we're going to say
when we've got childcare that's more
expensive than we would like and then we
want to try and bring the cost of that
childcare down and one of the reasons
for that is the ratio that seems a
reasonable thing to give people the
choice of something different and it's
up to them I think the most parents
don't really have a choice about the
ratios that the child care that they use
I think that's a choice for the sector
most of the sector have said they do not
want to reduce the ratios because they
do not have the training in place and
the qualifications in place to meet the
same ratio requirements that we have in
Scotland so there are a lot of concerns
about that but I want to ask you about
eligibility as well because
um the proposals vastly
um grow eligibility for the free
childcare hours however four out of five
low-income families are completely
locked out of the government's provision
can you explain how that's going to help
well low-income households but also
increase the workforce generally so
um they're not locked out I mean it's
the same eligibility that we already
have which is
requirements households under 20 000
pounds
and that's right because this is a
policy to support people in into work
how do you get those people into work if
you don't support them in childcare I've
just gone through so this this policy is
the OVR that have uh have actually said
which they've never done before for a
policy like this I think they have is
the single biggest contributor to the
increase in the workforce that they've
modeled which is I think 110 000 for
memory and aggregate the single largest
contributor to that was this policy so I
think actually our independent you know
the independent obr has said that it
will help improve labor Supply and and I
think it said the eligibility is done in
a similar way to the existing program I
think separately though it's important
there are also changes made to the
provision of childcare through Universal
Credit where you know people are not
always aware that 85 of child care costs
are reimbursed through Universal Credit
and the big call from people and now so
that particularly helps those on on
Lower incomes the big call from people
was to change how that system works so
instead of that child care payment
reimbursement happening in arrears it
could happen in advance there was also
some requests to change the Caps that
were applied in that and the
Chancellor's budget dealt with both of
those things so that those payments can
now be done or will be done in advance
the Caps have been raised and again you
know all these policies are warmly
welcomed by the childcare sector by
other parent groups as well and that's
because they've all improved the supply
of child care make it more affordable
and the zerobr have said lead to an
increase in in labor Supply which is why
they were so warmly welcomed at the time
they were announced sure I think
any chance
pressed about
it you must be aware of them surely that
the ratios are going to reduce quality
there's a crisis in the workforce with
30 thinking about leaving and we've
heard stories of going to work in
McDonald's and Asda because they pay
better so increasing the number of
children that each child carer has to
care for without putting in additional
support for training and is going to
potentially have the opposite effect and
um
the one of the missed opportunity really
big missed opportunities here is to
extend early years education to some of
the poorest households we also have a
challenge with training
why would you not allow a training nurse
for example or a paramedic to access
these free Child Care hours
I mean lots lots in there I think
they're just really important I think it
was missed in all of that there's been a
I think a 30 increase in the funding
rate for two-year-olds and that's going
to kick in from September of this year
now you know that incremental money
going in for the hourly rates will be
used by providers to make sure that
their their teams are paid properly and
to invest in in whatever they want to
cover that yeah and again again I think
that was as a 30 increase it was
requested and warmly welcomed
prime minister a very big issue of Child
Care on the petitions website
um so
um finally somebody's given me something
to do in this community which has so far
been very well behaved
um we'll move on to
um small boats
onto the small boats issue and we'll
start with the equalities committee
chair Caroline notes
prime minister the issue of children
arriving on small boats should children
in the care of the home office have the
same protections under the children act
as those in local Authority care
so it kind of I mean first of all look I
I the government everyone takes the
welfare of children incredibly seriously
as of course we should and it's
important that when it comes to this
policy that we're sensitive and that we
get it right and there's been a lot of
thought that's gone into getting it
right and I think we've we've got a
policy that does what we need it to do
which is treats people with decency
treats people humanely
safeguards Children's Welfare but also
achieves the objectives that we're
trying to achieve which is to break the
cycle of these criminal gangs and stop
people
coming here who shouldn't be coming here
and also some of them tragically die on
Route including children and I think we
struck the right balance in all of those
things so was that a no that there
shouldn't be equal protections under the
children's act I think they're a set of
I mean you brilliant is better than me I
think there are a set of very specific
laws that we have around corporate
parenting the distinguish between the
home office and local authorities and
which you would know better than me but
in all cases the welfare of children is
taken seriously Safeguard has taken
seriously there is support and
procedures in place to make sure
children are looked after properly in
all circumstances thank you the
safeguarding of children is indeed
important and in 2011 the independent
family returns panel was set up to
safeguard children in family units who
were being removed from the UK
their role has been disapplied from this
coming Friday so what measures will
there be in place to safeguard children
who are being removed as part of a
family unit
so as well I mean children are not
separated from families and they will be
made sure that the facilities for them
and the accommodation for them is
absolutely appropriate for them
oversight of that
well in the first instance it would be
the home office in terms of the when
people arrive in the fruition of those
facilities if you're asking from a legal
perspective so in 2011 the home office
brought in a panel specifically to
oversee the safeguarding yeah no yes so
I mean the home office can do that
itself okay so it no longer needs the
independent family returns panel at all
I mean we've got advice we've put in
place procedures and the home office is
perfectly capable of doing that okay
where specifically were family groups so
children with their parents who are
scheduled for removal be detained in
appropriate accommodation for them and
they won't be separated from their
families how much of that accommodation
is currently available at the moment
there are a few thousand places and more
are being built and there's a full team
at the home office that is working on
the Opera operationalization of the bill
and it's one of the things that they're
working through to make sure that it's
ready at the time the bill is in force a
few thousand places overall for capacity
but as I said families no no overall
right so specifically for families I
don't have an exact number but the point
is that they will be they will be
accommodated specifically in a
combination that's appropriate for them
and children would not be separated from
families no one will see that but there
will be powers to detain children with
their families that look the the
intention of this part of the policy you
know the policy objective here is is not
to detain children but it's important
that we don't inadvertently create a
policy that incentivizes people to bring
children who wouldn't otherwise come
here and that's why it's important that
it applies equally to families because
otherwise you increase the likelier that
people bring children here they make
very dangerous Crossings I don't think
anyone would want to see that that's not
good for children
um but the policy should and must apply
to families but it's right that then we
then look at families differently as we
do and they should be in accommodation
that's appropriate for them and that
those family groups should not be
separated I think that is that is the
right thing to do because otherwise you
know you create it as I said you create
an incentive for a criminal gang to tell
people to bring a child with them when
they otherwise wouldn't be and I don't
think that is a good thing I don't think
we want to create a pull factor to make
it more likely that children are being
making this very perilous journey in
conditions that are reporting I don't
think that's the right thing to do we
should not create a system that makes
that more likely no I think you're
absolutely right we shouldn't be
creating a system that makes that more
likely I'm interested in what measures
are going to be put in place to assess
vulnerabilities particularly under uh
those who have protected characteristics
so what measures to ascertain whether
women are pregnant whether people have
disabilities what protections there will
be for lgbtq people
so I mean well one of the things to do
first of all there's age
um actually is the first thing we've
talked about children so I think the
first thing is to make sure that we're
able to ascertain who are children and
need that extra safeguarding and the
nationality and borders Act established
a new decision-making function in the
home office
um
it's referred to as the national age
assessment board which will consist of
expert social workers
um who will conduct things like age
assessments on on full referral I think
that's a really important thing that
it's not easy and those things are
complex but it's right that we get those
right and I said the powers in the now
but will allow us to do that more
properly than what we do it properly
anyway but just to do that even more
comprehensively than we currently do it
will age assessments also be carried out
on older people
I think there's a well we have a I think
we have an initial way that we do age
assessments that the Supreme Court I
think unanimously said
um was lawful I think the reforms
through the nabba aim to make it more
comprehensive and more consistent and
robust from the outset as I said
there'll be expert social workers and
we're also considering how scientific
age assessment age assessment methods
could um could widen the evidence
available to decision makers and I think
the
um there's a committee that's also
published uh a report very recently
which the home office are currently
considering so the home office is adults
at risk policy which was last updated in
November of last year considered that
anyone over the age of 70 would be at
greater risk if they were detained
does that mean that people over 70 will
be excluded from the provisions of the
illegal migration bill because they
would be at greater risk if they were
detained
you know I haven't seen that report
Karen I apologize so I can't comment on
it I happily get back to you on it okay
thank you
um a final question from me so I've been
greatly exercised about how we're going
to afford protection to those who might
have been eligible under the arap scheme
or the Afghan citizens resettlement
scheme should they have not managed to
leave Afghanistan at the time of all
pitting and when the Arab scheme was in
full flow so what are we going to do to
make sure that those people who may well
have assisted the UK forces are not
going to be removed to Afghanistan and
how are we going to determine them
should they arrive here by small boat or
have already arrived here by small Bay
um so look we've already
I think we've already welcomed over 20
000 people across the two schemes we
have specifically for those from
Afghanistan Arab and acrs I think we I
think on on our app I think we're about
12 000 and there's not a cat scheme and
from memory and but there are
commitments to those specific people
that we've um
that we've made you know my
understanding is that you know we have a
way to talk to these people and
communicate with them
um and we in Afghanistan and then we'll
bring them here in a safe and legal way
and also through acrs you know there's
been there's three different Pathways of
that where people are leaving
Afghanistan and then we'll we'll come
here as well but you know so far as I
said over 20 23 000 already
um with a plan to keep going
um but I think part of the actually
illustrates the overall issue we've got
in the those are exactly people who we
want to help which is why in Afghan and
it was highlighted in the independent as
having been given notification that he
was likely to be removed to Rwanda yeah
I I can't really comment on the
individual case but if you send it to me
I'll happily make sure the home office
have a look but I think the general
point I'd make is you know it's right
that we have a migration system and an
asylum policy that targets our
generosity our compassion our resources
on the people that are most vulnerable
the people that we determine we want to
welcome here accepting that we're never
going to be able to bring everyone here
who would like to come here I think
everyone will acknowledge that and so
there's always difficult decisions to
make we want to make sure that we do
Target all of our power our passion our
generosity on those who we really want
to and at the moment what we have as a
system well that's not happening where
you know we have tens of thousands of
people coming illegally who are not in
that category you know and a third of
all small boat arrivals last year came
from Albania clearly it's not a system
that is targeted on the people who most
need our help and that's a system that I
think we probably agree we want to get
to and once we have proper control of
our borders once the bill delivers what
we need it to deliver then we're going
to be able to do a far better job of
having comprehensive safe and legal
routes and targeting as I said our
compassion our generosity our resources
on those who we most want to help that's
the type of country we are that's what
we've done in Spades over the last few
years in Syria and Afghanistan and
elsewhere and that's what we will always
do but at the moment our ability to do
that is limited by what's happening due
to Illegal migration
is it right that an Afghan female judge
or MP who arrives on a small boat should
be treated differently to an Afghan
female judge or MP who arrived here
prior to this legislation
I think again wrong again through cases
the point is we we have to break the
cycle of criminal gangs we have to stop
people dying when they are trying to
make these dangerous Journeys and we've
got to have a system which is fair for
everybody fair for taxpayers fair on
those who emigrate here legally Fair on
those who most need our help and that
means we have to have a system which
says if you do come here illegally
having multiple safe countries on your
way
um then it's reasonable that we detain
you and remove you to a safe alternative
let's just forget what are we doing here
we are making sure that people are
looked after they will be safe that will
either be in their home country whether
if that's appropriate for them all
Rwanda or other Alternatives down the
line you know that is a policy which is
reasonable it's fair and will ensure
that we can break the cycle of criminal
gangs continue to welcome refugees here
who we want to provide that Sanctuary
for and stop people dying needlessly
that is the system that we want to move
to and this is what the bill will
deliver
thank you
um
Sarah Champion the overseas development
assistance committee thank you chair
um prime minister recently you've been
speaking a lot about fairness and last
year you authorized an estimated 3.5
billion pounds of our overseas aid
budget to support refugees in the UK and
particularly on Hotel accommodation
managed by the home office
um you just said that you support
refugees coming here I think that's
absolutely the right thing to do but
you're using the aid budget to do it and
in doing so you're effectively turning
your back on the poorest in the world by
not addressing the very drivers that
force them to flee their homes so how
how is that approach Fair
um I you know I I think I'm very proud
of our record on Aid We're the third
largest donor in the G7 as a percentage
of GDP historically been a very
significant Aid donor and the way in
which we spend our Aid money is entirely
in line with the oecd's DAC committee's
guidelines on that as you'll be aware so
we follow all those guidelines and
indeed the Autumn statement last year
made additional money available to deal
with a particular circumstances of
Ukraine and also Afghanistan but
primarily Ukraine my question was on um
fairness yes it's within in the
guidelines but it's not within the
morality that the guidelines expect us
to follow and no other G7 country is
spending to that level so I wonder your
decision to prioritize Aid spending in
the UK and not therefore internationally
it has put immense strain on our support
for fragile countries around the world
to give you one example at very short
notice your government decided to cut
funding to a save the children project
in Afghanistan which is currently
supporting a hundred thousand women and
girls they're now going to have to wind
that project up why are you cutting Aid
to Afghanistan when the country is
undergoing such a massive humanitarian
crisis and of course women and girls are
at the front of that having their rights
stripped away from them
in the interest of being being brief
because I I know we need to go to a lot
to do but I'll I'll stay at the chair
stare at the beginning is that we are
one of the largest vendors on Aid
anywhere in the world 11 million
internationally and that that is the
reality of it our track record on this
is uh is very very strong and goes about
Harry's question right at the beginning
and clearly people like to spend more on
lots of things because it's been common
is to say well where's that money meant
to come from
um but with regard to Afghanistan in
particular
um you know we are a leading donor to
the situation in Afghanistan I think
we've committed something like 200
million pounds since spring of last year
at least you talk about women and girls
at least half
um uh of those that we reach with our
interventions in Afghanistan should be
women and girls and we also co-hosted a
very successful um pledging Summit
alongside Germany and Qatar last year
which raised over two billion dollars
for the un's Afghanistan appeal
early announcement
you describe compassion generosity and
finding the resources when it comes to
supporting refugees in the UK
um
do you have that same approach when it
comes to supporting the poorest in the
world because under your watch as
Chancellor you oversaw both the merger
and significant cuts to our ability to
support people around the world what
impact has that had on your
International standing and that of the
government
well actually I I I'll let others
comment on on International standing I
think in the last few weeks we've
demonstrated that we're trusted and
respected Ally around the world and
you've seen that from the engagement
I've been having whether that's in
Europe whether that's in France whether
that's with our Australian and American
Allies all of those conversations that
I'm having are incredibly positive in
fact with world leaders they recognize
our leading role on some of these things
I've discussed particularly Afghanistan
um with some of my counterparts over the
last few weeks our leadership on climate
is another area
um where I think we have a very strong
track record
um small island developing States I was
just seeing the Prime Minister of
Barbados recently and discussing that
and again just recognizes our leadership
on that and then in Ukraine again and
we're not just are we providing Military
Support but also humanitarian support so
I think we have a very strong track
record it's our engagement and support
is warmly welcomed around the world I
you know no one has no other leaders
have raised with me any issues in that
regard indeed actually they want to work
with us and and are very grateful for
the the role that we play have any
leaders in the global South raise that
with you in fact I should as I've been
talking to when I've been talking to
leaders around the world there so
they're generally all very grateful the
last conversation and I have with many
of those leaders at the G20
um was around our Global fund commitment
uh which they were all very grateful for
actually
um and specifically did tell me that
because we've committed a billion pounds
to the global fund that will help tackle
TB malaria Aids HIV other things
um and that was the announcement that we
made around that time that was what the
leaders uh who you know who actually
spoke to me about and they were very
grateful for the UK and I'm very glad to
hear your commitment to International
Development so can I ask you a specific
question that links to my first
um why is it that you are not
instructing the treasury to ring fence a
specific budget to support refugees in
the UK why is it that you think it's
fine to raid the overseas development
assistance budget again I just don't
want to say at the beginning Sarah we
act in line with the dark rules we're
completely in compliance with all of
those and we've provided I think an
additional two billion pounds to support
um uh to for extra financial support to
to accept the fact that the Ukraine
situation was exceptional and there was
extra funding made available for that
but as I said we remain one of the
leading Spenders on International
Development anywhere in the world thank
you prime minister thank you Jim thank
you sir
um damn Diana Johnson from the home
Affairs committee
uh good afternoon I think it's very
clear that we're all committed to
stopping the small boats and you've made
it one of your five priorities I just
wondered to this end we've got 140
million pounds already spent with Rwanda
on the deal there 500 million pounds
that you've agreed to send to the French
to build a Detention Center which will
be operational in a few years time we
don't know what the figures are around
using RAF scampton and and ferries and
there's no impact assessment about the
current illegal migration bill that's
going through Parliament although the
refugee Council seem to be claiming that
it'll cost nine billion pounds over
three years so I just wondered is there
actually a blank check from the treasury
for you to achieve stopping the boats
of course not
um but what I can tell you and the
number you didn't mention is that we're
spending three and a half billion pounds
a year currently on an asylum system we
spent six and a half million pounds a
day roughly how housing Asylum seekers
in hotels and and you know we need to
make sure that that we bring that down
over time and again as a matter of
fairness and stopping people tragically
living their lives we do need to stop
the boat yes and there's no fun as I've
always said there's no one silver bullet
that will solve this problem there's
lots of different things that we need to
do and some of them are returns
agreements and others are new pieces of
legislation there is more cooperation
with the French there's and we're
working on all of them can I just ask
you then it's right isn't it that the
permanent secretary in the home office
still hasn't uh signed off the Rwanda
dealer's value for money because of the
lack of evidence of a deterrent Affair
that's correct isn't it yeah look it's a
it's a I mean it's a novel policy and
that's why the bill yes so the answer is
yes sorry I think I should I think
actually the refugee counselors I think
that does have a they think it would
have a deterrent effect okay but um I
think as as you said Don I think we are
I mean we're very committed to stopping
how are they going to do it this is this
is what I think the right way uh to do
it is other people may have Alternatives
but having spent a lot of time on it and
having seen lots of other ways that
people have come with a problem you know
I think this is the only way right to do
it can I just ask you then given that
the illegal migration Bill Provisions
are now going to be back dated to the
7th of March and uh it's being promised
that we're going to see Rwanda
departures flights to Rwanda departing
by the summer
small boats already should be there
should be a deterrent there already in
action but actually this year we've had
3770 people arrive in small boats since
January 1st so why do you think there's
not been any um evidence of a deterrent
effect so far I just just to pick up
what you said I know no one has promised
uh flights by the summer what we've said
is we will get it no that's not that's
not that's not what she said um you know
what we've said is we will start flights
as as soon as we can after legal
proceedings have completed and as you
know and as you know that there's been
one high court judgment already and
that's being appealed government
continue to defend its case but
ultimately we need to let the legal
process play out and it's only after
that the legal process has been
completed now people may speculate on
when that is likely to happen or not but
it's only when that process has been
completed that we can practically start
the flights and I believe it's at that
moment that you will be able to see and
you will start to see a
but it was right that we backdated uh
the legislation because otherwise again
you create an incentive for people to
come very quickly in search which
obviously that wouldn't be sensible
either so it's the appropriate and
sensible thing to do to back date the
legislation from the day of introduction
okay what happens if your um if your
priority to stop the boats what happens
if they
if they're Plan B well I said we're
focused on delivering the policy so as I
said there's lots of different aspects
to it whether it's cooperation with a
French whether it's returns agreements
whether it's more enforcement whether
it's a legislation whether it's the
backlog we're working hard on all of
them right so no plan B so on in
December when you came before the
committee uh I think you just announced
then your plans to abolish the backlog
in Asylum claims and at that time the
total backlog stood at 120 000. it's now
at 166 000. so I just wondered how you
were getting on so I think I was very
specific with you at the time as I was
in Parliament that what we were talking
about was the initial Asylum backlog
which are the times did it I think about
90 2000 from memory uh the latest
published figures on that have it are I
believe 88 but they are a month or two
out of date from memory so you know it's
lower than that now but we are making
progress on reducing the initial Asylum
backlog so I think you've kind of
acknowledged that and I think again we'd
agree that just stop the boats we need
to cut the backlog restore return
agreements with the EU safe and legal
routes tackling the trafficking guns
could you just also at this stage just
rule out leaving the ehcr as irrelevant
to actually dealing with the small boats
problem and so we believe that our bill
is compliant with the echr that's the
government's view obviously there's a
section 191b statement given the novel
nature of it but you know what they're
my belief is that the bill is compliant
with easy HR okay and just finally could
you just explain uh to me why the term
institutionally racist sexist sexist and
homophobic is deemed to be politically
charged by the Home Secretary but the
use of the term invasion is not
well I mean I think I addressed that
previously anyway and uh in pmqs the
other day but I think that the findings
of the Casey report are shocking it's
appalling and it's right that action is
taken uh by all those who have
responsibility whether that's the net
commissioner or indeed the mayor of
London who is a of course the person
with primary accountability politically
for the Met to make improvements and
it's not it's not politically charged
using the word Invasion as that we've
got to the Casey report it's important
that changes are made I'm asking you
about Invasion use of the word Invasion
to describe the small boats problem I
think look it's very clear that the
scale of the problem is significant and
growing I mean when you've when you've
had a quadrupling or quintupling of the
number of illegal arrivals in the space
of just two years as important to
actually recognize the pace of what's
happening and that's a very large number
and it's growing very quickly but my
specific question is is it politically
charged to use the word invasion in
relation to the small
what I would say is the situation is one
that is significant and it's growing and
it's important that we take action to
stop it
well it seems to me that it is
politically charged to use the word
Invasion I mean we know that use use of
that type of word inflames people and
gets the far right particularly inflamed
well I think I think actually what
matters are actions and I think what
people want to see is that we're taking
actions so and I think that's you know
that's what we're doing whether it's
with the legislation it's a cooperation
with the French all the other things
we're doing I think what what that
demonstrates is action to grip a problem
which is significant and growing okay I
think language matters prime minister
thank you
Thank you Pam Diana so we're now going
to move on to the Northern Ireland
protocol and the Windsor framework uh to
the Northern Ireland committee Simon
Hall thank you chairman good afternoon
prime minister
and uh first of all can I just say
um thank you for taking Northern Ireland
seriously
uh which is refreshing and that is being
heard I think live
across uh Northern Ireland
um now for those who are prepared to
sacrifice the good in pursuit of the
non-existent perfect
would be helpful for those who are doing
business and politics in Northern
Ireland to understand what I think is
correct
which is that it's the Windsor framework
which amends the protocol
or the protocol unamended that there is
no scope for further negotiations with
the European Union
in the interest of brevity that is right
I'm I'm glad about that no because
business tells me uh on in many
conversations that the key thing that
they want is certainty and stability is
it your hope that as a result of
securing the Windsor framework both of
those from a business perspective are
achievable in the short term uh yes and
indeed actually there were many business
groups that are in the government
engaged with over the process the
process of negotiating The Windsor
framework understanding the challenges
of protocol and it is certainty
stability Simplicity
um were other things that were mentioned
in fact there were several criteria and
I'm confident that the protocol delivers
on uh well sorry the framework delivers
on all the requirements that business
have put to us that were important to
them but stability and certainty were
critical because businesses need that to
plan
business business and many of the
political parties a lot of trade bodies
and trade organizations are now very
keen now that the Sands have settled for
wanted a better phrase to maximize the
opportunities as and when they can of
that unique trading position of one foot
in both camps one within the UK internal
market and one within the EU single
Market given that economic development
is devolved to storm locked and Stormont
isn't City in order to demonstrate to
business and The Wider Community the
prosperity that can flow from this
what can your government do to fill that
Gap created by storm once hopefully
temporary suspension
well I think you know when we we
continue as a UK government to Bang the
Drum for for the UK more generally with
businesses around the world and you know
sell the Windsor framework as well to to
businesses because it does present
opportunities to invest in Northern
Ireland but I think the most important
thing is you alluded to Simon was having
a executive up and running it's all
that's the most important thing because
it's right for the people of Northern
Ireland have their own government up and
running they cannot really take and make
these decisions because Northern
Ireland's future from an economic
perspective with the Windsor framework
is bright and what we should be doing is
seizing all the opportunities that exist
in it that's what businesses are Keen to
do and that would they would be better
served by having a government up and
running
thank you
last week the commission was in Belfast
and in Dublin so our apologies for
missing the vote on the uh framework I I
would have been probably traveling you
in the queue to be first through the
door to support it
but clearly Ango Irish relations have
been under considerable strain they are
our very near neighbor
um
the the signing of the framework appears
to have opened the door for a
significant Improvement in anglo-irish
relations how do you see that of itself
helping the wider economy of Northern
Ireland
you know I think it was something that
was important to me that we had good
relations with the Republic I spoke to
the t-shock on I think my first day in
office and I was the first prime
minister to attend the British Irish
Council
um in over a decade and
you know I'm grateful for the support of
the Irish government in in helping us
and supporting us to reach a a good
agreement with the EU about about
um what worked for Northern Ireland and
I think actually more broadly than what
you've just said it's not just with the
Republic but with countries more
generally across Europe actually with
the pro the issues with the protocol
resolved you know hopefully it does
unlock operation in other areas but the
Primacy here was to do what was right
for the people of Northern Ireland for
their communities or their businesses uh
restore the balance in the Belfast Good
Friday agreement that was the thing that
we were aiming for that's the thing that
I believe we've achieved with the winter
framework and you know the fact it is a
nice and added bonus that hopefully that
that means good strong positive
cooperation with allies uh on a range of
other topics as well obviously this year
we're celebrating the 25th anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement something
that I've always seen is sort of having
choose according to two sides one is
peace and the other is prosperity
and the prosperity has been felt by
quite a large section of Northern Irish
Society in both communities
but still in some or for some again in
both communities
that buoyancy of prosperity hasn't been
felt leading them to have questions
about what the Good Friday agreement
means for them and the doing of politics
in Northern Ireland can achieve for
their lives is it your hope that sort of
settling protocol issues through Windsor
seeing stability and certainty for
business that wider ripple effect
beneficial ripple effect of prosperity
can be felt
across all strands of societies in
Northern Ireland so that they can see
the benefit of Peace stability and
prosperity I think you've put it very
well and I hope that that does happen
and the anniversary with a good Friday
agreement gives us a chance to reflect
on the progress we've made and the
opportunities that lie ahead and as I
said when I talk to businesses I see an
enormous desire from them to support the
northern Irish economy you know there's
amazing talent there there are fantastic
industries that already exist that are
world class so there's an enormous
potential actually
The Windsor framework hopefully we can
build on that attract more investment
spread more opportunity and prosperity
to make sure everyone in Northern
Ireland feels the benefits of it and
they can look forward to a brighter
future but again all of that I think
rests on there being a government there
that represents the people of Northern
Ireland and that's why we should all you
know hope that we can see that as soon
as possible thank you thank you Mr Burns
um Agnes McNeil for international trade
committee I go to Lodge uh Mr chairman
just permanently before we get going
um last week you gave quote a helpful
answer to prime minister's questions to
my colleague Joanna Cherry who'd raised
the issue of female judges from
Afghanistan there's a foundation based
in my constituency run by John and Laura
norgov in memory of the daughter of
Linda nordgroff who was tragically
killed in Afghanistan and she was trying
to be liberated by Coalition forces what
they've done is they've set up our
foundation to help young Afghan women
and they want to take about 20 female
medical students to complete their
studies in across the five medical
schools in Scotland the medical schools
in Scotland are happy this happens
everybody involved has happened it's
happy this happens but there's a problem
with the home office I wonder as prime
minister can you intervene to help the
situation to make sure these young
ladies do complete their studies in
medicine
but I'm sure if uh if you if you write
me and indeed the Home Secretary and the
immigration Minister will make sure that
their case gets looked at in the normal
way but I think with all immigration
cases whenever I'm asked the same thing
that's the right process that should be
followed but I'm very happy to do that
if you just make sure that they write in
with the details and someone at the home
office will have a look at this thank
you there are letters already in but I
just want to highlight that to you uh
personally at Prime Minister we have a
new first minister in Scotland uh I
think he wanted a section 30 for a
referendum and I think you've rebuffed
that idea is that correct seven haven't
had the opportunity to talk to the new
uh first Minister yet so I look forward
to doing that and uh in the section 30
then so I look forward to having that
conversation with him if you don't grant
that section 30 it would be that you
don't want school and have a referendum
and in that case why would you prefer
Scotland to go down the election route
for Independence rather than the
referendum route I said I'm looking
forward having a dialogue with the new
first Minister and you know as I've
always said I you know I think actually
what people in Scotland want is to see
their two governments working together
to deliver for them I was pleased that
um one of the last things I was able to
do with the previous first Minister was
announced two new freeports in uh
which again I think you know she she
welcomed rightly as a good example of
that cooperation delivering jobs and
opportunities you said something quite
important what does people in Scotland
want now the world is watching the
Democratic world the good guys and the
non-democratic world the bad guys if the
people in Scotland speak at the ballot
books for Independence or not do you
think it's incumbent on us all to
respect that voice of the people at the
ballot books I think in in elections
people vote on all sorts of different
things and I don't think it's
appropriate to try and hijack a general
election for foreign democracy to say
anything you want in a Manifesto are you
trying to prescribe the manifesto that
somebody would run on I I mean I think
that's what the previous first Minister
was was trying to do and I think
actually people in people in Scotland
will vote on the various issues that
they think are important to them so as
the rest of the world might recognize
that result you might have Iceland you
might have the nordics you might have
the baltics for example all recognizing
us the people of Scotland would are you
saying that you'd unilaterally deny
Independence or attempt to unilaterally
deny that the Scottish people had spoken
for Independence situation to get
yourself into I I think we we did have a
referendum on
its energy are you denying that on that
we were told it was a once in a
generation referendum Scotland had an
opportunity to express uh to express
their views and and they did so I don't
think anyone could deny that they were
given that challenge we're also a
subsequent to that delivered on all the
commitments that were made all the
commitments that were made to devolve
greater power to Scotland which is now
the most I think the most powerful
devolved assembly anywhere in the world
those commitments have made people of
Scotland those equipments have been
delivered and actually what they're also
seeing now is strong cooperation where
we can to deliver for them whether it's
on the cost of living whether it's all
things like freeports and that's what
we're going to continue I'm glad to see
that you don't rule out a recognizing
The Ballot Box and you're you're
predecessor but one did call the 2019
general election he wants in a lifetime
general election and I hope you're not
going to take him at his word on that
when it comes to Northern Ireland you're
a fan of the single Market no when did
you take the road to Damascus on that
very issue
uh no I think what I was referring to
and actually it's as I'd say sad that
we're having this conversation again
because I think what I was very clearly
referring to is this is the unique
status of Northern Ireland in the United
Kingdom because it's the only part of
the United Kingdom that shares a land
border with a member of the EU and also
as a part of our country that has had a
history of troubles and the balance of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement is
incredibly important to ensuring
stability and peace in Northern Ireland
and it was decided by everybody that we
shouldn't have a harm border on the
island of Ireland and that's why
Northern Ireland has a special and
unique status inside the United Kingdom
that I think everyone acknowledges and
actually trying to make political points
about that I don't think it's
appropriate and I think it's very clear
that Northern Ireland is different in
that regard and and it's right that we
respect the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and the balance that is
required to make sure that the agreement
works properly 180 degree turn on the
single Market it is important because
you know and you will have certainly
known as Chancellor that it's a four
percent or five percent damage to GDP is
this choice for the UK to leave the
single market and the Customs Union it
is affected people on the day-to-day
it's affecting that their costs of
living
um so prime prime minister
if it's okay for Northern Ireland and
you see it's got a board of European
market well with the south of England is
20 miles away by ferry it's not far away
by ferry
companies come to me in trade and they
tell me that it'll be far better for
them to be
in the European market single market
then the situation they can't they have
it's paperwork Central
again I just put up said previously at
Northern Ireland I think it's really
like not to recognize the unique and
special status of Northern Ireland
inside the United Kingdom because of the
history of what's happened in that part
of our country which you know we've had
an appropriate discussion on the
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement which good reminder of the
delicate situation in Northern Ireland
and it's right that we treat that
situation with the consideration that it
deserves and recognize that we do need
to ensure that all strands of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement are
respected and it's important to avoid a
hard border on the island of Ireland and
that's why we need a special set of
solutions for Northern Ireland which
we've now found with the Windsor
framework I just want to touch on why
the three dishes but just a small data
printer see would you understand about
you might own Airline but budget
deficits in the 78 years since 1945 how
many years has the UK been in deficit
would you approximate
it's very rare for countries to run
overall budget surpluses yeah it's 67
years and the UK has only paid its way
for 11 years out of that money that's
been borrowed in here but 1.7 of that
has been returned
given the economic plates and the way
they are moving at the moment and with
the Americans pursuing the inflation
reduction act uh on the European Union
with the sea bands the carbon border
adjustment mechanisms and state-age
changes who do you think the UK is going
to respond so it doesn't get
economically squeezed between these two
Big Blocks
as you know there are board rooms
everywhere making decisions on where
they're going to invest and you
mentioned earlier investment by
companies in the UK being a problem for
productivity surely this uh leaves you a
huge problem uh for improving
productivity with those massive tectonic
plates moving on the small UK in the
middle not part of either so so actually
we're also making progress on Carver
border adjustment mechanism and
something that I had conversations with
my European counterparts including Olaf
shorts when I was doing my previous job
and we the treasury is carrying on that
work so we're actually similar to the EU
looking at what appropriate carbon
border adjustment mechanisms are because
they are reasonable and Central sensible
things to implement and actually you
know very well be that there is in the
same way that for Missions trading
schemes and things as opportunities for
cooperation across those
um it may well be that those work well
so actually we're having conversations
on Common Board or adjustment mechanisms
and as it is and with regard to foreign
direct investment UK has got an
incredible track record in attracting
foreign direct investment and pointed
out the survey of three or four thousand
Global CEOs from over 100 countries who
just a few months ago named the UK as
their number one European investment
destination behind over the US and China
which is an enormous statement of
Confidence from uh Global business in
the UK and I think you're starting to
change against us and you get many
attention what I'd just like to say
finally a prime minister is the as we
mentioned earlier the damage to brexit
is 45 of GDP to the economy which you
were one of the politicians who chose
that
um the trade agreements
are yielding very little
perhaps 0.02 to 0.08 it's like throwing
away four or five hundred pounds to get
two pounds or eight pounds back
the department of trade is is changing
and altering and being merged as Youth
Government finally recognizing that
because maybe also like freeports that
trade agreements have very little to
give GDP in relation to the huge damage
that's been chosen to do to the UK
economy with brexit
I'm just surprised that the uh you're
having a go at Freeport and we've just
announced two with the Scottish
government to deliver in Scotland
because I think they do agree as we have
done in uh
is probably recognition from the SNP
government
were actually a good thing and they are
uh they are something that we can do
post-brexit we can do properly inside
now we can and it's great that we can
announce two in Wales uh last week two
in in Scotland uh previously and there's
a good example
when you talk about brexit there are
many opportunities uh of brexit trade
deals are one things like freeports are
another
immigration uh regulatory change and I
know obviously in Scotland has chosen
not to take advantage for example of the
new Gene editing bills that are actually
going to increase uh food productivity
in other parts
and actually you know whether it's
missing Life Sciences Financial Services
has such a strong financial services
industry and actually it's going to
benefit enormously from the chancellors
these are all fantastic opportunities
for brexit as I said whether it's uh
whether it's Financial Services whether
it's what we can do in life sciences
we want to make sure we deliver those
benefits across the UK and I'm glad we
could do that
you were way over time Mr McNiel and
off-peaste uh but you are entitled to
ask your own questions
just before uh prime minister just
before Dame Diana has to leave to return
to the chamber can I just ask a a
supplementary and there are a number of
newspaper reports
that have that reflect
a clear briefing that the Rwanda boats
are going to to flights are going to go
this summer
um is there something you want to put on
the record about that or have you got
nothing to add to what's been I think
what I've said to you today I've said
publicly when I've given interviews and
I may well have said it on in in the
house but uh I'd say the same thing
we will get flights to Rwanda as soon as
we can after the legal proceedings right
have been completed okay but in the
interest of time but it's uh okay um our
last question is Sir William cash or
back on the protocol
thank you very much so back to Windsor
uh prime minister uh you said yesterday
I was very pleased to hear this I am
very clear that I passionately believe
in our Union
so so do I and I'm very very glad to
hear you say that but how does that
relate to Northern Ireland's status
within the union because this Windsor
agreement is meant to be a permanent
Arrangement so won't Northern Ireland be
perpetually locked into subjugation to
Eve law
make making uh with the imposition of
not only
existing
pre-brexit laws in the single Market
such as manufacturing Goods but also
many new EU laws
which is blatantly as a whole
inconsistent with a real Union can you
help with that I find it very difficult
to reconcile your passion for the union
with the fact that EU
law prevails to such an extent in
relation to the single markets and in
Northern Ireland they're just completely
fundamentally inconsistent well I I
think as we've discussed this before
um bill I think recognizing that the
Belfast Good Friday agreement should be
respected and the balance of it should
be respected and that means that you
know there is as I was clear from the
outset there is a small amount three
percent of EU law that does apply in
Northern Ireland
um but two two things that to bear in
mind when it comes to this issue of
sovereignty and one is that because of
the storm on break as it if a new and
amended EU laws the institutions of
stormwater people of Northern Ireland
actually will have the ability to have
their say uh over those laws and
ultimately we'll be able to block them
if they don't agree with them
um but just to answer right at the
beginning it's important to remember
that even in the original protocol the
entire thing is subject to a consent
note and that you know so this is only
any of this is only there with the
overall consent
um of Northern Ireland but what we've
done with the storm on break is make
that more granular so that for
individual rather than All or Nothing
um a choice on an individual basis as
new or amended laws come down the track
storm will be able to have it say and
we'll be able to block them for the UK
government and as you know I'm not very
keen on the Winds of framework as you
know but having said that on the
question of the storm won't break
um and what you've said about is this is
intended to provide for Democratic
consent but don't you accept that the
break does not apply to and it can't
apply to existing EU pre-brexit laws but
nor does it apply to such vital law
making issues as state aid children
markets the at excise and much of
customs
so what effect do you think all this
will have
on the rest of the United Kingdom in
terms of Divergence
well actually it refers in an Article 13
3 as you know in the annex that's
attached to it to the specific set of
goods customs and other rules that I
think are referred to in the same way in
the dup7 test so I think it does
actually refer to the rules of people uh
we're most concerned about and that's
something that they had raised with me
previously and it as it refers because
if you look at their seven tests and
what they refer to this encapsulates
exactly that set of rules not
necessarily for vat because we have a
separate set of changes on vat is you're
aware and when I was Chancellor I cut
v80 on solar panels I was not able to
apply in Northern Ireland as a result of
the Windsor framework it now will we
reformed alcohol duties and want to have
a lower rate of beer Duty and pubs
relative to supermarkets that wasn't
able to apply that now will and so
actually on those things I think there's
been enormous progress as a result of
the Windsor framework and and the storm
on break is a very powerful mechanism uh
you know with regard to Divergence in
general all and you know I'm confident
that actually many of the the things
that on this we do agree Bill the
advantages of brexit the ability to
deregulate in areas like services for
example there's complete flexibility on
consumer competition
um social Etc all those things are out
with the protocol that's where the bulk
of the economy and growth is and that's
where we have the ability to do things
differently and we are and you saw more
of that from the chancer in the budget
and we will be able to do that across
the UK just that finally just on this
question of sovereignty and democracy
actually I don't believe that the
Stormont break will achieve the kind of
objectives that have been set but we
won't go into the details of that that's
quite a complicated story but actually I
do think that the question of
sovereignty does lie at the heart of
this and I don't think that the people
of Northern Ireland are being given the
benefit of the sovereignty of the United
Kingdom it's not a real Union in that
context and I just ask you if you'd like
to reflect on the fact that the Windsor
framework does not represent the kind of
Union that the people of Northern
Ireland or reasonably to expect
on this respectfully Bill we'll have to
disagree and I believe the Windsor
framework does do that I think it
ensures the free flow of uh of goods
within our United Kingdom by The
Establishment and expansion of the Green
Lane and the facilities for supermarkets
I think it ensures Northern Ireland's
place in our Union in all those everyday
things like the tax changes we've talked
about what's available in garden centers
taking your petinal holiday what
medicines you can get and crucially I do
think that it ensures proper sovereignty
for people of Northern Ireland and
corrects the Democratic deficit because
of the storm won't break which Michelle
barnier's own advisor has described as
in in very powerful terms and that's why
I believe it's the right thing for
Northern Ireland's people for their
communities for their businesses this is
always about balance and we talked about
it previously this is about the balance
a delicate balance of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement the protocol had
disrupted that balance right of course I
mean we all acknowledge that and it was
right that we did something to address
that and the Windsor framework it does
that I believe and you know all the
engagement the time I've spent in
Northern Ireland the people I've spoken
to listening to what their concerns were
and I've done my best to address them
and I believe the Windsor framework
represents a fantastic foundation for us
to move forward and actually just build
that brighter future for Northern
Ireland which is there for the taking
um prime minister finally the
whole purpose of the Northern Ireland
protocol was to safeguard The Good
Friday agreement
but
The Good Friday agreement the power
sharing Good Friday agreements being the
casualty
and it was hoped that your discussions
with the European Union
would restore the Good Friday agreement
and restore power sharing
but the expectation of that is now what
and what happens if power sharing is not
restored
well I I remain hopeful that we can
continue to have dialogue with all the
parties in Northern Ireland I want to
see Power sharing up and running I think
everyone wants to see it and that's what
the people of Northern Ireland need and
deserve
the protocol was an obstacle to that but
the Windsor framework objectively does
deliver on ensuring that the challenges
of the protocol cause have been dealt
with it provides that foundation for us
to move forward and I would urge parties
to to think about that because that's
ultimately what we need in Northern
Ireland we need people to have their
institution up and running making
decisions for them and as we come up to
the anniversary of the Good Friday
agreements good reminder of how hard
fought these institutions are and we
should try and give them every chance of
succeeding in the future well I honestly
hope
the power sharing is restored but if the
Northern Ireland protocol continues to
undermine power sharing surely the
Northern Ireland protocol will one day
have to be replaced by something that
has the confidence of both communities
in Northern Ireland well then the the uh
the Northern Ireland protocol has been
changing and we now have the Windsor
framework and it does have I believe
broad support in Northern Ireland from
all the conversations I've had with
people from all communities from
businesses I think the Windsor framework
does have broad support and what I would
say to all parties now is to recognize
that and to look forward and give the
people of Northern Ireland the devolve
government that they need and deserve
well we will hope and pray for peace in
Northern Ireland and pray to be
sustained
um prime minister thank you very much
indeed for joining us we've gone a
little bit over time
for the most part everyone has been
extremely well behaved and your answers
has have been well I said for the most
part
um
the Prime Minister you'd be very helpful
to us to get through all our questions